[Musique]
alors qu'il a choisi de ne pas se
représenter à la présidence de la
communauté d'agglomération Robert
Cadalbert revient avec nous sur ces
années passé au service de 50 ans neline
et des cantinois c'est tout de suite
d'en bien
vivre
[Musique]
ces élections municipales vont permettre
de renouver la gouvernance de
l'agglomération et son
[Musique]
exécutif ce qu'il faut dire sur ces
élections municipales d'abord c'est que
tous les maires de saint-cantagne Line
qui soit de droite ou de gauche ont été
largement réélus dès le premier tour
sauf quand ils ont ont pas pu faire
l'union dans leur propre famille
politique c'est le cas à voisin c'est le
cas à trappe dans cette vague bleu
marine ou noire qui existe en France à
Saint-Quentin vine elle n'est pas là le
le discours du Front national qui est
contre la mondialisation contre l'Europe
contre l'euro contre les immigrés contre
tout le repli sur soi à sa-quentinine
avec des autres méthodes des méthodes
d'ouverture du vivre ensemble des
méthodes de du travail dans nos
différences enrichissement dans nos
différences le respect de l'autre le
travail en commun c'est ça qui amène la
réussite pour moi c'est le grand
enseignement de cette élection
municipale à 51
[Musique]
luine le bilan à 50 àine c'est d'abord
une réussite économique et une réussite
économique qui n'a de sens ce qui est et
se traduit par de l'emploi et je sais
qu'on a encore beaucoup de
travail le chômage est plus faible à 51
VI que ailleurs en France mais on peut
pas se satisfaire d'avoir une jeunesse
qui est encore au chômage pour moi c'est
insupportable et donc nous avons les
moyen grâce à la réite économique de
Saint-Quentin de Line que j'espère va
pouvoir durer dans le cadre du projet
Paris saclé par exemple il faut que tous
les habitants de Saint-Quentin puissent
en profiter et particulièrement notre
jeunesse l'implantation de notre groupe
remonte au début de la la ville
[Musique]
nouvelle et puis ensuite un immeuble a
été construit à venue du avenue du
centre et puis nous nous sommes étendus
dans le quartier toujours au cœur de
l'agglomération et nous avions quatre
implantations et nous avons souhaité les
regrouper nous venons de d'aménager il y
a un mois dans un immeuble rénové nous
avons fait ce choix de de de d'être et
de rester à 50 ans et nous y développer
parce que nous y trouvons pour nos
collaborateurs un cadre de vie agréable
beaucoup d'entre eux résident à
proximité et puis nous avons des
partenariats avec des grandes
entreprises également implantées dans
dans l'agglomération ainsi d'ailleurs
qu'avec l'université de de Saint-Quentin
donc c'est c'est nous sommes heureux et
fi d'avoir le siège de notre groupe à
Saint-Quentin nous sommes un groupe
mondial 12000 collaborateurs mais le
siège les 850 collaborateurs de ce siège
se trouve à
[Musique]
saint-gantin un territoire qui croit en
son avenir il croit en sa jeunesse et
donc il croit en son université c'est
pas simplement saint-qutinine demain
Paris sa clé c'est ensemble encore une
fois c'est ensemble qu'on réussi et ben
cette université elle est au service de
la jeunesse de son avenir et c'est ça
l'avenir d'un territoire sans la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans000
l'université ne serait pas tout au moins
dans ses composantes situé sur 50 ans
[Musique]
Eveline l'aide le soutien de la
communauté
d'aglo depuis la création l'université a
été très importante elle a participé au
financement des bâtiments encore
récemment bâtiment de l'UFR des Sciences
de la Santé donc c'est un budget un
investissement financier important de la
casassi tout au long de ces années qui
s'est jamais démenti également un
soutien en terme de de fonctionnement en
retour l'université apporte au
territoire aussi j'espère euh non
seulement en investissement direct parce
qu'il y a des étudiants qui consomment
sur place parce que il y a des salariés
d'université qui habitent sur 50 ans
nlin mais également nous participons à
la formation des étudiants qui ensuite
peuvent travailler dans les différentes
entreprises notamment des grandes
entreprises situées sur le territoire il
y a tout toutes les partenariats
recherche développement que nous pouvons
avoir avec les acteurs économiques du
territoire je pense par exemple avec
Renault et donc je tiens à à remercier
le président cadal Albert pour son
soutien hein pour son appui à
l'université tout au long de de ses
mandats et j'espère
que il en sera de même avec le prochain
président voire même que l'appui pourra
s'emplifier soyons soyons optimistes et
rêvons un
peu la capacité qu'on a eu dès le départ
à mettre quelques moyens depuis la
Maison pour tous jusqu'à la scène
nationale à ce que effectivement la
culture nous inonde nous immerge et nous
amène à vivre ensemble dans la meilleure
façon possible encore une fois en
respectant la différence de l'autre dans
le le projet commun c'est ça
effectivement la culture à sainttin moi
je suis arrivé en
2005 j'ai été frappé par le par le
niveau de d'équipement culturel à 50 an
d' c'est c'est quand même c'est dans les
gènes je dirais de la ville nouvelle la
culture
[Musique]
il y a pas beaucoup de vill de 140000
habitants qui on un niveau d'équipement
en France en toute la France de cette de
ce niveaul et de cette qualité là moi ce
qui m'a frappé énormément déjà c'est le
niveau des le réseau des
médiathèques avec un lectorat je crois
qu'on bat les records de France du point
de vue du lectorat une ville qui non
seulement avait déjà haut niveau
d'équipement mais qui en plus j'ai vu
construire un conservatoire à à trappe
celui de guillancour celui de la
verrière et donc une une ville nouvelle
qui non seulement est très équipé mais
en plus consolide et renforce ses
équipements aussi bien en terme de
diffusion de spectacle la seule ville en
France en dehors de Paris qui a une
maison de la poésie en tout cas de ce
niveau-là qui a autant de théâtre de de
salles de spectacles petite moyenne ou
grande avec des des qualités de
programmation qui du coup sont très
complémentaires et puis des salles qui
fonctionnent quand moi je suis arrivé en
2005 un des projets de pour pour laass
nationale c'était de créer une saison
jeune publique bon j'ai eu un appui très
fort de l'aglomération pour monter cette
session jeune publique au TER de 50 an
et puis on a lancé l'idée de la
coordonner avec les autres lieux tout a
fonctionné à fond complètement au niveau
de la
[Musique]
fréquentation on est une des rares
villes de l'île-defance avoir autant
mordu on va dire sur un nouveau
public aller au-delà des publics
habituels des salles de spectacles on
sait sur certains spectacles qu'il y a
un tiers de public qui vient par le
biais effectivement de cet accent
culturel
[Musique]
anine a eu la bê d'art et d'histoire à
cause de la de la de la politique on va
dire d'implantation depuis les origines
de d'œuvre d'art dans la ville et puis
une certaine conception dire de de
l'urbanisme ou de de la qualité
architecturale de certains ensembles une
grande partie de l'identité de 5ine
passe à travers la culture parce qu'en
fait c'est quoi une ville c'est quoi
c'est c'est c'est c'est ce que les gens
peuvent partager quel que soit leur
origine leur milieu le leur
fortune social le pays d'où ils viennent
et
cetera la santé à partir de du travail
qu'on a fait sur le développement du
sur la qualité de vie à satin divine
avec aussi l'arrivée de notre UFR des
sciences de la santé fac de médecine
nous avons passé je pense un cadre
supplémentaire le la santé c'est pas
simplement les maladies et comment on
lutte contre les maladies la santé c'est
effectivement la prévention et je crois
qu'avec l'Institut de promotion de la
santé qu'on a mis en place depuis
maintenant plus de 10 ans pour nous
c'est la qualité de vie à Saint-Quentin
Ninine et donc le bien-être
Saint-Quentin est un territoire où les
familles sont arrivées jeunes actives il
y a 40 ans sont resté sur le territoire
vieillissent du coup sur ce territoire
font même venir leurs parents ce qui
explique le résultat des différentes
études qui ont été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mené Saint-Quentin est un territoire où
qui vieillit plus vite que les autres
les autres villes du département des
ivelines les conséquences
de ce vieillissement sont bah une
nécessité d'adapter des infrastructures
d'adapter les réponses au au
problématique aux préoccupations que
peuvent avoir les personnes les
personnes âgées qui peuvent être en
perte d'autonomie le groupement gér
handicap est le résultat de d'un projet
porté par la Communauté d'Agglomération
en partenariat avec notamment le Conseil
Général et tous les
professionnels du du domaine de la perte
d'autonomie de la gérontologie et du
handicap pour répondre à une
problématique des sa-quantinois au
vieillissement de la population et
apporter des réponses adaptées en terme
de maintien domicile des personnes qui
vieillissent sur le territoire de
saint-quanttin en
nieline le bilan qu'on peut tirer de
cette réussite cette réussite au service
de tous même s'il encore beaucoup de
choses à faire que effectivement pour
que cette réussite continue c'est une
méthode c'est une méthode du du
travailler ensemble et l'enrichissement
de différence au service d'un projet
aujourd'hui l'agglomération c'est cette
commune peut-être beaucoup plus demain
c'est Paris sa-clé après-demain et donc
il faut qu'on continue dans cette même
volonté de travailler ensemble
entreprise collectivité territoriale
association et c'est ça qui fait la
vraie réussite de Saint-Quentin divine
et je doute pas que le prochain
président de la gouveration même s'il a
pas la même sensibilité que moi aura à
cœur de maintenir cette méthode de
travail qui est basé sur la confiance le
respect et la rigueur dans nos projets
et pour la réussite de nos
projets un dossier que vous pouvez
retrouver dans le petit qutin du mois
d'avril ainsi qu'un focus sur mire et
Frésil de solidarité nouvelle pour le
logement et un article sur la meilleure
manière de réussir un entretien
d'embauche grâce au
[Musique]
théâtre
ah